guten morgen 10 uhr weil ich so in etwa
ist hängt ein bisschen an zu nieseln
das ist ein bisschen frisch also 25 grad
oder so bisher war das wetter echt nicht
so bombe aber für die sachen die wir
machen wollten hat mir ganz gutes wetter
hier sind jetzt gerade hier in wien star
hinten
die kleinste die irgendwo unser plan ist
jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal frühstücken
und danach ins national history museum
weil das wetter endlich so ein bisschen
zu es fängt langsam an zu regnen oder
ist das museum falls jemand nicht kennt
aus nachts im museum heißen new yorker
verkehr einfach absoluter stillstand
ist da ganz sind oder die brüder
übrigens hier ich war heute morgen am
bluten und
eine freundin wird gerade partners ist
mit kleinerer italiener
flüchtlingslagern im kopf entfernt seite
von hudson river gezeichnet wie eben
jetzt hier wieder treffen und nach mega
drive ich kann jedem nur empfehlen und
bei den new yorker unbedingt hin zu
gehen dass dessen jean pierre egger
knapp so lecker bedeutete mir egal es
ist einfach metern 34
alle freunde wir sind gerade einander
bekommen die eventuell kennt und zwar
system ages babbel ich kenne ich
wahrscheinlich er unternahm mclarens von
how i met your mother und zwar werden
wir das versuchen reinzugehen ich weiß
allerdings nicht ob das klappt ja das
ist ja mal dabei da steht auf den
schildern draußen freundin und dann in
der bar die sich bereit für alles ein
bisschen anders
also wenn ich euch dass meine grenzen
zeigt ist die schüsse aus wie eine firma
als politik gedreht und ihr seht ihr ein
paar bilder davon da oben ist
beispielsweise t
dahinten demokraten bild von nay und die
mutter ist halt auch nicht wieder
allerdings sieht komplett anders aus
denn schon gedacht eventuell ist der
eingang und er die außenszenen erfolgen
den hollywood gedreht worden oder es
hier drin wird oben getrieben hat nur
nach oben und wir müssen etwas essen
bekanntes gemüse kam
meine freunde sind grad im national
history museum das ist ein museum unter
anderem nachts im museum und alle
möglichen anderen filme gedreht werden
die new york stattfinden und in einem
museum wollen wir sind jetzt hier gerade
dem as rom das heißt jetzt alles
mögliche gesteine unsere vormund unseren
chat und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
passiert wenn wir uns jetzt auch diesen
riesigen - auftraten gucken und
launchpad
freunde der braut aus dem museum war
eigentlich ganz in ordnung an manchen
stellen langweilig an manchen stellen
interessant wie beispielsweise beim gum
typen haus nachts im museum jedenfalls
laufen wir jetzt über die canals schritt
in richtung broadway
das ist da wo casey nice day wo wir den
besuch hatten unter der wohnung
sonderurlaub pizza und danach wollten
wir zu chinatown
wir waren jetzt gerade in chinatown und
jetzt sind wir world tour wird elia sie
sind jetzt gerade lately ankommt und
wenn euch das hier mal anschaut es ist
einfach so mitten noch in china hier
sind noch überall so chinesische
schriftzeichen und so weiter wir werden
jetzt wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
rumlaufen mal schauen was es hier
vergibt lassen uns weiter ausbaut und
danach auch schon zurück ins hostel hat
es schon 18 uhr wir wollen heute nicht
allzu spät wieder da sein also um 20 uhr
wollt mir schon spätestens im haus der
seien noch ein bisschen doch schön weil
ich auch morgen wieder zurückfliegen und
nach berlin und so freunde findet wieder
zurück in unserem hotel queens blase wir
haben noch einen autofahrer gesehen der
als nummernschild einfach stronger hatte
und jetzt begeben wir uns gerade drückt
und wir sind schon deutet jedenfalls
würde ich sagen was es jetzt heute vom
morgen noch den letzten wieder wo ich
wieder zurück fliege und nach berlin
fliegen acta zusammen
durchgefallen habe ich mich über
bewertungen freuen und